In Moscow
today, a court
ordered the arrest of well-known
investigative journalist
Christo grows up and grows out of
who works with.
Bellingcat has an extensive track
record of uncovering stories
exposing the Kremlin.
And Vladimir Putin
herself was a key
figure in investigating the plot.
To kill Russian opposition leader
Alexei Navalny and has been on
Russia's most wanted list since December.
He joins me for an exclusive interview
Christo, thank you very much
for being with us.
To the best of your understanding,
why did Russia order your arrest?
What reason did they give?
Well, the mystery began
about four months ago
when I was put on the international
wanted list by Russia.
And they had absolutely no information
put out there.
Why they're looking for
me around the world.
It just said for breaking the law.
And today,
during the arrest hearings in Moscow,
I found out for the first time
that actually the reason
why they have been looking for me
or want to arrest me and are inviting me
is because apparently in their views,
I organized the escape from Russia
of a persecuted
Russian called a Russian journalist
from the of whom
they raided
the house of his parents house.
And he left Russia
in the middle of the night
one Friday, about a couple of years ago.
So they are saying that
I organized all of that.
And if that's the charge that I
have to live with, then
I could be happier.
Is that something you were involved with?
Well, let's leave it at
that, that I would gladly help
any help any Russian
journalist get out of the country
if they are
if they feel prosecuted or persecuted.
There had been this report
and that Russian investigators had
told the court
an illegal crossing of
the border of the Russian Federation.
That's what that was in reference to.
Correct.
There was some misunderstanding
by colleagues, by media
who thought they had crossed
the border illegally.
I would never dare do that.
I mean, I've been blacklisted
by Russia since 2006.
Never crossed into it.
But but yeah, it's a colleague
who crossed the border without a passport
because they had four feet
of this passport
a couple of hours earlier.
And I'm kind of the conspirator
or the organizer of that event
in their eyes.
In terms of your reporting.
I mean, obviously,
you have been in the forefront
of some extraordinary work.
Do you believe there's
a particular piece of your reporting
that Russian authorities
have been been singling you out for?
Anderson, take your pick.
I mean, I've covered the shoot down
by Malaysia,
by Russian
air forces of Malaysian airliner, MH 17.
I've covered the Skripal poisoning,
the explosions around Munich in Europe,
the Navalny pausing.
I think the Navalny poisoning was one
that was particularly painful
for the Russian FSB,
for the security machine, because it
not only disclosed that they did it,
but put them in a very,
very, let's say, unflattering
light of bumbling idiot.
So I would
I would take
that as my book has being on
Russia's wanted list.
Has it affected your life?
I mean, obviously,
you have to take
that kind of thing very seriously.
Well, clearly, I cannot travel to
certain countries
that previously
I would have traveled
to for investigations
and for journalistic purposes.
I have to think twice
before leaving the country
I am in the moment.
But I would say that
that's not the scariest thing out there,
because being on the wanted
list is one thing.
Russia always delves into sort of
lanes.
They have the judicial
sort of pursuit and persecution,
and then they have the extrajudicial
one and
today, by the way, in addition to me
being put on the on
being arrested virtually,
which is the crazy
Russian invention
arrest in absentia, I was also put on the
what they call
the foreign agent list
for the first time,
which is strange because I'm a foreigner.
So I obviously
belong on a foreign agent list
because otherwise you should be
there as well.
But together with me, a couple of Russian
journalists were put on the list,
including a very brave
young lady who was poisoned
in the last few months.
By the same machine, repressive machine.
So that's that
just gives you an indication
that being pursued
within the
confines of the law
is not the scariest thing.
Yeah.
I mean, obviously, we have seen
people poisoned in in foreign countries
by Russian by Russian agents.
That's got to be something.
I mean, you are
obviously very aware of it's
got to be something
that I mean, does it change the way you
operate on a daily basis?
Definitely.
I mean, you do have to think twice before
touching a door handle
and then accepting tea from a stranger
or water from a stranger
that may
have to become your second nature.
And all of my colleagues at Bellingcat
have kind of
had to learn to live
with this new escalated risk,
as many Russian colleagues of ours
have done for years.
Crystal Groves,
I appreciate your time tonight.
Thank you very much.